makes us take pictures with santa no  matter how old we are so i'm going to go  through some of our santa pictures we've  taken as adults i'm not going to lie  this santa looked very scared this was  the same santa he  still looked scared didn't look any  better this year we decided to play a  prank on my mom you can see gabriel's  taking a selfie adam and chazz are  fighting brian's hitting the jewel i'm  passed out drunk austin's making out  with his girlfriend amelia's on her  phone and eva's pregnant my mom was not  thrilled about this and santa  wasn't either and finally this was a  socially distanced picture with santa  because it covered eva couldn't make it  so we have her cut out honestly i think  we won santa over by this year he looks  pretty happy